[Music]
all right gonna pull the next article
here
oh what's that whoa is that a daily
double daily doubt it's the jk news
article of the
i'll day big booties for 500. it's not
that so a husband has been slammed for
upgrading to business class on a flight
and leaving his wife in economy
it's a compliment he's saying babe
you're so skinny you're already in
business class
interesting that was
very good oh no sir no this guy this
absolute [ __ ] savage
he's on a flight within savage no not
randy savage
okay his friends his wife are headed to
japan from the united states
for a month-long vacation because they
got a quarantine there for like a couple
weeks oh [ __ ] so he books the flights
right and they initially thought that
they were gonna be sitting next to each
other but then he realized he has the
option to upgrade his seat to business
because he has miles and so he does that
and after revealing his plans his wife
was not too happy about the situation
because she wanted them to sit together
during the 12-hour long flight but they
sit together every day
you're going through it together bro
it's not looking good for this woman
you're going through it together maybe
she would quit nagging him all the time
am i right
you wouldn't want to go eight he
wouldn't want to get away from her
that's been argued by the way or maybe
he farts a lot like me
and he doesn't want to ruin her ride
oh he's very considerate and he's like
you know what let me get out of the same
cabin because she's going to be even be
able to smell it if i move seats
so bad that they can't survive in the
[ __ ] wind tunnel that is an airplane
i don't know ask geo she says it smells
bad even on a plane though because i
know it smells bad i've smelled your
farts before i'm talking about one time
we're flying somewhere and then she fell
asleep with her head on my lap and then
so i was like oh she's not gonna hear
anything i just kept bloody letting him
rip and then she woke up when she woke
up she said what the [ __ ] does this
smell like [ __ ] in here and all the [ __ ]
i don't know i've been smelling the same
thing
i have to tell her like three days later
because i felt bad
what did she do when she got a match she
made a fuss of it of course she made it
so [ __ ] predictable
were you just sweating every time
up until that time you told her were you
just worried i know it's nothing you
know but he was just a wreck for those
three days this is also the guy that
like had food poisoning on their like
second date shad all over her walls or
whatever right so you shell over her
walls and scrapes it off the tile with
his fingernail
i told her what happened right away
but he had to wait three days for the
fart because after you guys get together
there's a different side that comes out
i'm trying to maintain you don't need to
tell somebody that you just had a
blowout in the shower though
some things you could just protect and
keep i think you could have kept both of
those to yourself yeah but bart says
full transparency he really means it as
long as it's a three-day window though
you know i am a fan of that so this man
what do you guys think right
you're on a flight 12 hours this guy's a
piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah this guy's a
dick but now we're going to defend him
i want to know their dynamic though to
see if there's anything just no he mocks
or he says that she's just jealous and
since she refused this guy sucks bro are
they children in a playground he's just
jealous he says i'm not gonna miss my
opportunity to sit in business class
in my eyes it's just a 12 hour flight
doesn't matter if i sit next to my wife
or not who cares he's like i never did a
12 hour flight in a business class
before at the same time she chose him
getting weird yeah you know it's her
fault because she chose them no i mean
like like
not that it's her fault that's good bart
not that it's her fault but i missed you
yesterday i know what you mean i know
what you mean he probably does this [ __ ]
all the time in different ways and
you're still married i know i know she's
wack right date one on date one this guy
was a [ __ ] douche and you ignored it
date two you ignored it she had known on
day one when they asked you to marry her
girl you already know man like that yeah
so at the same time you chose him you
know she should have known on day one
when he took you to a restaurant he got
the best [ __ ] steak everything and he
got you the bread that was free
and he didn't let you order anything
else
and he got the rib eye yeah he got the
kobe beef and then you're like i want
the lobster roll he's like wait wait
wait wait you want that for you don't
want the lava just get the get the
caesar salad i'll get that it's jelly
roll or something oh it's like on the
day it's like hey you said it can you
sit at the kitty table i'm gonna go sit
at this one
we're both eating why do we need to be
together a 12-hour flight is a [ __ ]
kind of a nightmare yeah it's horrible
so you know
if it was like a two-hour flight it's
like why wouldn't you want your wife
what i don't understand is did he not
have enough points for the both of you
no he did not is he just like oh my god
here's the thing i could upgrade this
aren't you supposed to give it to the
wife yeah isn't it the whole [ __ ]
thing which is why you don't give it to
your wife you just both sit in economy
yes yes yes and then and then one day
because you both had to send the economy
and fly both ways now you got more
points now use the points for just
yourself secretly wow
when she's not around because sometimes
you might travel without her for work
your dancers have some moves i never
even knew yeah
dancers are sneaky huh this guy sucks
though yeah what type of asian would you
tell us he's got to be japanese is that
a japanese move
he's an alcoholic wife beaten japanese
guy that could be a chinese it's all
reddit names because even though
newsweek is covering this it's an am i
the [ __ ]
but i got this from the news he's asking
he's asking no yeah he's asking if he's
an [ __ ] yeah he's an [ __ ] yeah
yeah his name's can over seven that's
what he that's what his mind how long
hasn't i wonder how long they've been
married because this sounds like some
40-year marriage soon doesn't say at 40
or mayors though she can't get mad maybe
she didn't even complain because we
don't even know
maybe she was like oh who wrote the
article then uh in terms of i am oh he
wrote it he was asking if he's an
[ __ ] well yeah he wrote it on reddit
yeah so if you need to ask maybe she
didn't tell him maybe she's awesome then
to me this is just one of
look it's chivalry is dead and all that
[ __ ] right but
if you're going to get an upgrade you
give it to your chick every time so
sugar's not dead well yeah but exactly
but everyone but isn't that
it's just weird like you're not
traveling with your friend and even if
you are traveling with your friend
that's weird too yeah it is weird like
if if we're gonna go somewhere together
yeah and then it's like yeah oh one of
us gets the all right i'll see you later
hey would you leave me actually though
if you travel all the time that's
different
but if it's like a group trip and it's
like all right guys
we're all going to cancun and then don't
you want to sit together so you could
drink and talk or it's like you know
when you and your friends are going to
switch locations and there's three cars
then you distribute it so that there's a
person there's at least two in each
you don't go all right this dude's gonna
drive by himself but the rest of you
pack eight people in this [ __ ] band
like no you don't care like the bus has
one seat left and then you go i'll see
you there you're walking
it's like i'll get off the bus we'll
walk together yeah it's just like just
to be cool was there context of like uh
they were going on vacation or was like
a workshop a month long
trip to japan i bet that trip was really
fun i know dude you don't piss these
[ __ ] off on the way that's why i got
some three days later see you take the
business class and say oh stranded at
the front he should have used his
[ __ ] points for the hotel room that
they would both use
you know what i mean he used points for
a lot of [ __ ] you use points for so many
things so the rental car that they'll
both be in you can use airline points
for everything else you don't think it's
smart to say that she's just jealous
[Laughter]
she sounds great she he really said that
in there yeah he said she's just jealous
she's just this guy sucks then they
probably both have never traveled that
much there must be like some [ __ ]
weirdness about that well what do you
guys think about going to a movie
together because if you're not going to
talk to each other at all
like let's say we have like [ __ ] nine
people and we're going to a movie
together we all can't sit together
obviously because we bought our tickets
late one person has a seat facing the
other way
honey you take that one here like this i
think it's great i think it's it's
circles circumstantial if everybody
understands the variables and makes the
call together yeah but like when you
like one person by themselves like uh
hey i'm gonna buy all your tickets you
guys are in the back row and i'm gonna
be in the middle
you know what i'm saying and you just
made that choice like why [ __ ] you make
that choice you guys gotta make the
choice together sounds super foreign to
us because i'm sure all of us come from
the background of like you wanting good
people riding with the boys yeah you're
right you're a girl you're always like
telling your girl you take it yeah can
we try to argue why this guy's maybe a
little bit of a legend too if it's
possible that's your job
maybe maybe she like [ __ ] hates
flying
right and the kind of thing that's like
it's a lot of anxiety and stuff like
that and so maybe he actually to like
better their entire trip i won't be with
you to comfort you not not but won't be
with you cover but it's like you also
know that you pissed me off when you're
anxious for 12 hours and i can't stand
that oh dude i think i still want to
travel i know i suck when i travel i'm
not cranky i'm cranky wouldn't the
anxiety be better
in business
i know
this is not too scary it was too big
it's like the pillows are too soft
there's like four cup holders and then
yeah you've got that whole thing yeah
the stewardess give you too much service
yeah you want to be nice and snug in
economy you just get the hotter
stewardesses up there yeah i want them
they're too hot yeah they're way harder
yeah she might get intimidated she won't
appreciate them
yeah she won't appreciate the
stewardesses girls do judge each other
so she looks away
[ __ ] no dude this is difficult
i can get behind that yeah yeah
what else is there he's a traditional
man you know like he sees her as his
property and he goes you don't need the
business card you're my property you
will go sit in the back stay in the back
with the chickens
as they walk through the cabins he
looked at everybody in business class
and like oh these are [ __ ] pedos and
[ __ ] rapists and you know protecting
rich drug
in the event of a plane crash most of
the fatalities happen in business class
exactly
99.3 survival rate for economy so the
people in the back are way better off
yeah i thought the pilot like pops a
willy at the last second so the bat can
land first
okay like a mosque rocket wheel here no
they just split the plane in two so each
side has a wig they fend for themselves
and just float themselves good luck
she hates his alcohol problem
he can't fly without drinking oh okay
and then they have free unlimited
alcohol in the business class
being considerate which is why he didn't
tell her about the upgrade until it's
like they had to you know force
themselves in that situation so he could
bypass that moment
lesser of two evils as he was walking on
he should have like paid a stewardess to
be like oh we've selected you to go to
first class and he goes oh what me oh
wow anything goes up that'd be good
she's like why not me though oh sorry
just one it's part of the promotion and
then we just like to split up couples
how about he she was going to watch the
eternals and he's like he thinks that
the new phase of marvel movies suck at
oh did you watch the internals i
couldn't get through her
it was so [ __ ] boring it was
too long i'd rather watch shakespeare
honestly it's not bad on hbo max when
you don't have to like pay for it
that review
it banned it it is so [ __ ]
we saw in the theater and we were like
we shouldn't have saw this in the
theater yeah yeah yeah is that bad it's
not that bad
it was just like it was kind of
underwhelming yeah just like i'd rather
watch kenneth branagh's hamlet it was a
typical like superhero movie but with no
variation like nothing cool nothing
exciting i'd rather watch a beaver eat a
donut you're all naming great things by
the way how about it but but here's what
i like when i watch a superhero movie i
like to know maybe who the [ __ ] the
superhero is that's all
it was difficult to follow too many
people there's way too many people
which is why he's got to be in first
class with less people but i did like
that everyone's less
i like that part of the movie yeah
everybody everybody's lives they wrote
each other out oh wow that's awesome
that's awesome that was awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you